et au menu des échanges la question
environnement environnementale le
racisme ou encore la crise sanitaire
sujet sur lequel est revenu sergueï
lavrov lors de son intervention le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères a
déploré certaines stratégies de
communication en pleine pandémie
à moscou la correspondance d'antoine
clairan le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères dans son intervention a
dénoncé à plusieurs reprises l'égoïsme
des pays occidentaux ou encore leur
volonté de tirer des avantages
politiques de la situation sanitaire
actuelle il est également revenu sur les
dernières sanctions imposées contre
moscou des sanctions ciblées contre des
fonctionnaires des hauts responsables
liée à l'emprisonnement d'alexei nava
liée à son retour à moscou de façon
implicite sergey lavrov a donc évoqué le
sujet en dénonçant les campagnes
d'information à charge contre certains
pays aujourd'hui l'espace médiatique
mondiale est en train de devenir un lieu
de promotion d'intérêts géopolitiques
mercantile les campagnes agressives de
fait nous sape la stabilité politique
interne des états souverains provoque
des troubles et des actes de poupe
violence dans la foulée l'annoncé de ces
nouvelles sanctions contre moscou a été
commentée cette fois de manière plus
explicite par la porte parole de la
diplomatie russe
la décision de l'union européenne
d'étendre les sanctions personnelles
visant la russie en raison de la
situation concernant navalni n'est qu'un
cirque est une histoire jouée d'avancé
comme il est de coutume dans les
relations diplomatiques entre et à toute
nouvelle sanction appelle la plupart du
temps à des contres sanctions
équivalentes mais cette fois ci cela
pourra aller plus loin le ministère
russe des affaires étrangères a laissé
entendre que la russie pourrait tout
bonnement au rompre ses relations avec
l'union européenne si les autorités
juste qu'il n'existe pas de coopération
d'égal à égal entre moscou et bruxelles